unhelpful of us yeah you're not gonna I
can already tell but do it anyway
unhelpful advice with Bobby
kalila and his best buddy re voice from
so black hi oh my from Minnesota here
just recently broke up with my boyfriend
of four years I initiated the break-up
and it was really sad for both of us we
got a place together a cat I really
wanted everything to work out but deep
down I was really unhappy how do I move
on from this and do you have any advice
on how to get to know yourself again
after being with someone for so long how
long there's four years and she's an
Asian girl from Minnesota how old no age
can I tell you something somebody just
wrote this out yeah this goes with semi
naked pictures on snapchat she yeah from
Minnesota Asian girl for years yeah the
cat's for real oh yeah where'd she look
like no Instagram are you being real
yeah I'm big because I put a thing on
Twitter it's like ask your questions can
I see your handle just so I could see
what she looks real
that's [ __ ] went off a little bit and
then the cats in the four years and she
was like yeah I just kind of a four year
relationship well looks like she's doing
just fine then if she's able to say oh
she's pretty good yeah yeah yeah then
she's fine oh yeah I thought you were
joking
whoa that's crazy crazy wait I
understand she wrote you she wrote us
how does she find you they're all up
listen they all bleed over yeah you know
that right yeah so what was her problem
again already already I don't we want to
hear how do you move off in your
relationship by sending nudes or Tommy
Jews over here wow that's crazy
we have no advice for you fine so Ari's
Netflix special Ari's gonna go to New
York he plays at the cellar a lot right
so this thing and all that
I got a podcast called skeptic tank yeah
and this is was a great one I felt like
let me see something right now I felt at
times in this podcast was very
uncomfortable was when you heard it
talks up your butt no that was fine
definitely emotionally weird yeah I felt
a little about because now I was able to
analyze the thing I like to see it in
from his point of view and I could have
handled myself this is the first time I
thought that I was that I could have
done a lot of things differently and
then I would like fault
everyone goes I was not at fault at all
and any any conflict right but I was and
I my eyes I saw it and that felt made me
feel comfortable and that was it was
just a revelation this one so I mean the
next time he comes back we can get back
into normal things but no more twin
that's why you bought [ __ ] candy bars
and put them in the freezer every brand
logical warfare this is one of those
like I'm gonna do Tiger belly I know you
guys get crazy I've heard [ __ ] I'm like
I know the last time what's your
apartment somewhere else would you like
what were you doing like we were putting
Kenny was like yeah we're good be doing
that we're gonna be doing down on Tiger
bone supposed to give this lady
oh I mean at this point it's boys with
high anyway it's time that's just how it
works when people are heartbroken you're
like he won't be in [ __ ] a year it's
so funny because when I was 19 I used to
drive by this girl Rebecca Dreskin
apartment in PV know and she would drive
new at like around 1:30 she got home
from work and she would keep the lights
on when she was undressing to put on her
you know right
that's you still looks a little bit
through the [ __ ] window because you
were deep had your nose on the window I
was talking that was with my brother one
time my brother goes man this is weird
and I used to I thought I did that all
the time weird [ __ ] and I was obsessed
and heartbroken you know and I'm just
not like that you change yeah right I
don't know if I can get like that for a
girl anymore
I just I'm honestly don't know it's been
missed that feeling 2009 despair for
somebody like in your twenties yeah it's
it's like having a high I feel that too
they're like cool a nightmare is a once
in a while yeah like I love you very
much
it's a steady love yeah but I don't feel
desperate for you you never know life is
consumed by it yeah like every song is
about it
I remember being Hawaii I miss all right
and there was nothing compares to you
was playing on this little radio yeah
and I was literally crying thinking of
this girl in Para black yeah I mean it's
like little it was and now I mean I love
Kyla she's like family yeah you know
she's beautiful and all that but I don't
have that like crushing mmm emotional
thing yeah and that's but the thing is
that's not real what do you mean it's
not real you're young
yeah it's you don't have but that's what
you can get someone to like kill their
husband yeah yeah you know I'm jealous
of all those women on snapped because
they they're in their 40s and they still
kill people so they've had to have felt
that type of desperation at that age
yeah people who don't like Marc Maron
who still fought like Paul's in love all
the time the people that always eat them
up on top of everything they love
beginnings yeah they love beginnings and
they love that feeling of the first six
months and then it's like on - I have
friends like they get all in a jump
astray yeah like pedal-to-the-metal yeah
but the excitement of just me being in
my career my other things I like I mean
there are just so many other things I
don't just get you know love isn't my
whole the center of my universe
right I love kalila she's we're partners
but one of my 20 is it was what I lived
for what it's poor love right now it's
not the center its Microsoft my sobriety
it's you know other things politics I'm
concerned there's so many different
things that you think about in your day
but back when I was young it was all
about love and [ __ ] I'm sorry I was
think about your dick it's so dark
are you sorry right now what I just saw
well you put your parents yeah my dick
is also dark it's awful here with myself
I like the color gray oh yeah yep I
always say it's et in the river when he
was sick do you know the L'Engle ears
yeah this Stephen King book about how
these people on a plane and sort of the
day like eats itself yeah every day yeah
yeah yeah cleaned up and these people
got through into the where the world was
getting clean yeah and everything is
like a little dark like stuff doesn't
taste like they find food but it's like
there's no taste to it and there's like
you say my cake yeah your dick is in the
language I'm gonna let that go I don't
think you saw it clearly
I'm clearly not let me see it so dark
it's dark yeah it's like it as a
gradation to it it's very light up to
the tip nice pink pink and gray cut that
out it looks like what all that rabbit
anyway on thanks for coming by everybody
you guys want to plug it one more time
[Music]